[Music]
what were we searching this site
tesladeaths.com yes okay tesla deaths is
a record of tesla accidents that involve
the driver occupant cyclist motorcyclist
or pedestrian death whether or not the
tesla or its driver were at fault tesla
deaths total as of 9 7 20 21 207 tesla
deaths in total that's it
i mean search the number of car deaths
this year it's like 207. oh [ __ ] number
of automobile deaths 20 20. 36 000
people 30 38 000 people i think what
people are
maybe trying to document is the
um
so the one that like freak like kind of
creeped me out was the sudden
accelerations claim
or like segment like if you just click
sudden accelerations
on the top ma'am
that freaked me out that like
you know they basically got like the
prius problem
what is it what happens i think it's
just like the car just auto accelerates
because it's like a os thing
it's a software thing what you know no
it's not like a drive-by-wire
mechanism so it's it's probably like you
hit the pedal and it sends a signal to
the battery to like you know
spin the wheels
yeah but i was reading was it the prius
problem or it was some other
uh form of toyota i think
where they were having this problem like
people kept
reporting that their car
would start accelerating as the prius
but wasn't it like didn't they do an
investigation they found out it was just
the type of person like the type of
person to the demographic that buys
priuses are more likely to hit the
acceleration instead of the break oh
they're trying to break or maybe i'm
totally wrong on that but i think that's
true right no i was looking into that
literally last night jesus
that's a god i was looking into that
last night and yeah one of the results
that they found was the mats were too
large
the petals were too similar and the type
of people who drove it
weren't hitting the brakes when they
should they were just slamming on
whatever pedal they were already
touching kind of convenient do we really
trust a big car organization to admit a
lot of these like cliff notes on these
deaths are just
just so insensitive like what tire
strikes tesla tesla kills pedestrian
tesla turns into oncoming traffic tesla
strikes impact attenuator tesla and
monsters
okay just like yeah just could like your
death is just a footnote yeah in the
last column of this spreadsheet tesla
kills motorcyclists while killing
cyclists i wish i knew if this was like
the autopilot or what that's what i want
to know but maybe it's just dumping date
how did the top it says only 10 of the
deaths were from autopilot i see i don't
know there seems to be this wild
campaign on the internet of people who
just think it's a piece of [ __ ] car
that's overpriced and has all these
problems and
it is i think that's true yeah yeah i
mean obviously i agree with that as well
i think that they've always been
like i my mom has one i've driven it
before i like it it drives fast it's
it's not not fun to drive but the inside
has always been like a plastic piece of
[ __ ] always i don't know why they
thought it was cool to make it super
minimal with one giant screen
i'll tell you it's like that to me is
like if i'm paying that much money for a
car i want like
mercedes like
led lights you can change the colors it
looks like this yeah i want comfy ass
massage seats i don't want a [ __ ]
golf cart you know it's part of my new
material
what so it's 100k golf cart man oh yeah
like a footnote and
yeah i rant about all this [ __ ] but i
want buttons you know yeah they said
like we keep taking buttons out of the
thing it should look like the inside of
a like a gamer computer if you pay 100
yeah that's that's where mercedes and
rolls-royce has it right yep yeah i want
latches and buttons and i don't know
what any of them do half of them don't
even do anything i want to click one and
then like you know well gun holder the
reason oh damn i don't even know
am i supposed to have a gun in here the
reason it's so minimal is because they
have no money left to actually put it in
the car
the goal goes to the battery and it's
like
it's [ __ ] literally like a spirit
airline flight of car yeah
but it's the pricing is inverse yeah
it's crazy how like a kia has more
luxury than a tesla yeah i agree that's
why i hate the
the pride that tesla owners have yeah
they know your car stinks man
it [ __ ] sucks you're driving an ipad
on bicycle tires an ipad is actually a
nice piece of technology
like it's sleek it's there's a lot of
like there's years of craftsmanship that
that went into an ipad i know but then
they just put that in a car and suddenly
cars 100k it's like no that doesn't add
up oh i see what you're saying you're
saying they just stick the other yeah
it's just like that yeah yeah and then
it wrapped around it and then everyone's
like you can you can change the horn
that is actually pretty tight yeah you
paid 100 g's to change the horn they are
really good at doing that that's been
their strength since the very beginning
it's like putting in these dinky stupid
features that are like anti-car yeah
that you've you know you're
30 years on earth you've never seen a
car do that before so you're like
what you know that's so cool yeah it
farts instead of honks hey you're in my
way yeah that's what the tesla deaths
are from yeah people trying to honk but
they forgot to change it apart
the autopilot is taking over they're
trying to stop there's a pedestrian in
front
the other deaths are from the drivers
being like to their friends you can play
you can play pong on here watch this
you can watch youtube on here
check it out there's a full browser
here's my openc wallet look at all my
nfts
it's like no it's a pug and a duck
combined check this out i got the duck
his friend steers the car and crashed
him
you're good we're [ __ ] yeah no he's
trying to kill him so he can get the
padduck oh i see he steers him off and
he unbuckles his seatbelt what are you
doing
then he then the friend survives and
retains the duck that's gonna be action
movies in the future people getting
murdered and then logging another open
seat wallet and be like we have to
transfer all the people yes yeah all the
ducks quick get the holographic padock
i remember that when i got my car it got
delivered to my place flex
and uh the the guy from the dealership
was like this really weird like i had to
ask him to put a mask on this was like
in the midst of coven oh yeah last
november so he was a year ago right
shit's peaking again i'm scared as [ __ ]
he's like uh i had to ask him to put him
out cause i'm sitting in the [ __ ] car
with me showing me the features yeah
it's a contained little box yeah it's
like dude can you put a mask on please
he's like oh yeah sure [ __ ] puts it
on and then he's like shows me this
compartment he's like yeah that's for
your glock
and i was like i don't
have one of those what else could it be
used and he's like oh well and he just
pulls it out yeah well actually comes
with the car you're like awesome then
you put your [ __ ] um
your goddamn
uh what's the name of this stupid [ __ ]
that keeps your water cold
ice
wait no the the slurpee cup no yeah yeah
yeah yeah might as well go talk slurpee
yeah start thinking of the it's like the
visco chick meme yeah yeah um the
hydroflask hydroflask yeah like that
goes for your glock 19 you're like cool
you put water in there and he's like
well that's for later when i'm thirsty
because i got two in the cup holders as
well that's for your glock 19 you want
to know it's colder than steel man put
slushy cup in there
you ever tried this [ __ ] you try to
crunch that up crunch it up dude
this is a fleshlight it could be okay
keep going keep going you see what's
happening in there a little ice
oh look at that it's a ice maker on the
way
you